im kleinen Dorf Ruthenberg haben die
Bewohner einen Kampf aufgenommen gegen
das sogenannte Königreich Deutschland
der vom Verfassungsschutz beobachtete
Verein versucht seit Monaten sich
Schritt für Schritt in der Gemeinde
niederzulassen mein Nachbarhaus war der
Anfang und es steht zu befürchten dass
das nicht dabei bleibt
unter uns ja ansiedeln die wir hinfahren
möchten auch Extremisten können Land
kaufen oder versuchen Mitglieder einer
Genossenschaft zu werden das sogenannte
Königreich Deutschland wurde 2012 in
einem verlassenen Krankenhaus in
Wittenberg gegründet in einer bizarren
Zeremonie Reichsapfel und Zepter Peter
Fitzek eingelernter Koch ließ sich zum
König ausrufen er bestreitet die
Existenz der Bundesrepublik als
legitimen Staat der Verfassungsschutz
beobachtet den extremistischen Verein
und ist sich sicher dass der sich
erstmals mit einem Agrarunternehmen in
Brandenburg niederlassen möchte ein
Video zeigt witzig im vergangenen Sommer
auf
Besichtigung neben ihm ein Landwirt der
bereits vor einem Jahr einen Hof in
Rutenberg erwarb der Biobauer stellt auf
der Homepage des sogenannten
Königreiches Pläne vor die weit in die
Zukunft reichen da wird der erste Hektar
jetzt angebaut mit diesem neuen
Bewässerungssystem was der nachhaltig
die nächsten 20 Jahre den Ertrag
abwerfen soll ne gegenüber dem ZDF
bestreitet der 37-Jährige jegliche
Zusammenarbeit mit dem selbst ernannten
Königreich Deutschland ein Interview
lehnt er ab geworden wird mit der Vision
einer Selbstversorgung mit
Bio-Lebensmitteln immer neue Anhänger
kommen ins Dorf die Kaufinteressenten
locken mit Geld nicht jeder im Dorf will
die Gefahr erkennen
[Musik]
ach nee
vom Vater
was macht der was hat er oder was hat
sich gemeldet doch mein Schildkröten
gemacht du hast ein anderer auch und er
hat er dann eben auch so
doch im Ort vermehrt sich Widerstand das
Bündnis Demokratie Rutenberg ein neu
gegründeter Verein will verhindern dass
die Dorfgemeinschaft von reichsbürgern
unterwandert wird die nicht auf den
ersten Blick als Verfassungsfeinde zu
erkennen sind
sind total nette Leute bis zu dem Moment
wo man über Politik redet dann haben die
wirklich irgendwie Knall im Kopf
generationsriedlich zusammen und jetzt
wollen sich hier Leute unter uns ja
ansiedeln die wir hier nicht haben
möchten wir wollen eben Antworten haben
wie man sich dem entgegenstellen kann
vor allen Dingen auch als einzelner
Bürger mit diesen Menschen als Nachbarn
das Bürgerbündnis ringt um Antworten
enttäuscht sind sie darüber dass die
Behörden bislang nicht einschreiten
dabei sind die Zukunft bedrohlich aus
der Verlassene Gasthof steht zum Verkauf
der pseudomonarch hat auch die
Agrargenossenschaft am Rande des Dorfes
besichtigt zu ihr gehören 44 Hektar
Acker und Wald damit würde der Phantom
Staat erstmals einen kompletten
landwirtschaftlichen Betrieb übernehmen
der dauerhaft Einnahmen verspricht der
Verfassungsschutz Brandenburg hat die
Bestrebungen des sogenannten
Königreiches Deutschland schon lange im
Visier doch sind ihm die Hände gebunden
solange sich die Anhänger an Recht und
Gesetz halten meint Referats
wenn Anhänger einer Reichsbürger
Bestrebung
auch formal legalen Weg probieren
irgendwie an Land zu kommen dann gibt es
nur relativ wenige Möglichkeiten das zu
unterbinden auch Extremisten können Land
kaufen oder versuche Mitglieder einer
Genossenschaft zu werden im benachbarten
Sachsen direkt an der Landesgrenze zu
Brandenburg soll dem Königreich gelungen
sein ein ganzes Schloss zu kaufen
dutzende Helfer leisten Arbeitseinsätze
zur Freude des vermeintlichen Königs und
mit euch merke ich kann ich das machen
vielen vielen Dank an euch alle
in Zukunft soll hier eine Gemeinschaft
abgeschottet von der Außenwelt entstehen
sein eigenes Königreich auszurufen das
scheint in Deutschland erlaubt zu sein
[Musik]
jeder der glaubt er könnte sich zum
König ausrufen soll das gerne tun
solange es dabei beläst wenn er aber
anfängt tatsächlich rechtsfreie Räume
auszurufen wenn er glaubte könnte
wirtschaftlich tätig werden und müsste
dann auch irgendwelche Gesetze des
Staates nicht mehr einhalten und diesen
Weg geht das Königreich Deutschland in
diesen Fällen müssen wir das Schwert des
Rechtsstaates ziehen und dort aufzeigen
die Grenzen was geht und was nicht geht
was alles geht zeigt sich in
Sachsen-Anhalt bringen Sie frische Ware
heute hier unterhält das sogenannte
Königreich Deutschland eine eigene
Ladenkette mitten in Tangermünde macht
der Betreiber des Geschäfts kein
Geheimnis aus seiner Verachtung für die
Bundesrepublik sein Laden für ihn
exteritoriales Gebiet denn wir hier
eintritt wird temporär Staats
zugehöriger des Königreiches Deutschland
so steht es an der Tür der Händler
Marcel Gast kandidierte für den Landtag
in dem Staat den er eigentlich ablehnt
ein Interview gibt auch er nicht obwohl
kein Gewerbe angemeldet ist lässt der
Bürgermeister den Laden nicht schließen
es geht kein Gewerbeanmeldung vor der
Unternehmer der dort tätig ist wurde
aufgefordert seine Unterlagen jetzt
einzureichen und da gibt es eine Frist
und wenn er die Frist einhält und seine
notwendige Unterlagen einreicht und kann
er damit durchaus weitermachen die Nähe
zum extremistischen Königreich gehe die
Stadt nichts an so heißt es aber an dem
harmlos klingenden Geschäftskonzept mit
regionalen Lebensmitteln zu handeln
findet der Bürgermeister offensichtlich
gefallen ich finde es ja unterm Strich
eigentlich gar nicht so uninteressant
der Laden der da insgesamt betrieben
wird das kennt man ja alles von früher
ich sage einfach mal bloß die Art und
Weise wie man dort möglicherweise
versucht den Rechtsstaat zu umgehen oder
das ist das ist jetzt nicht so unbedingt
unser Auftrag wir haben den anderen
Auftrag so wie der selbst ernannte
pseudomonarch bestreiten in Deutschland
etwa 23.000 sogenannte Reichsbürger die
Existenz des Staates des Bundesrepublik
der Verfassungsschutz warnt vor einer
wachsenden Gefahr
in der Ideologie von reichsbürgern ist
es fast angelegt dass sie irgendwann
versuchen sich zu wehren denn sie
probieren ja ihre Art Fantasiegebilde
durchzusetzen sie stoßen an die Grenzen
des Rechtsstaates der dann handeln muss
und dann neigen halt einige Reichsbürger
dazu eben Gewalt anzuwenden und das ist
bei Reichsbürger wirklich die große
Gefahr diese Gefahr sieht
Tischlermeister düwenhöcker auch für die
180 Bewohner von Rothenberg herausziehen
er und seine Mitstreiter vom
Bürgerbündnis wollen nicht locker lassen
vielleicht schaffen wir es ja doch noch
dass die hier einfach wieder abhauen um
das zu erreichen will das Bürgerbündnis
künftig genau hinschauen etwa wenn die
neuendorfbewohner gemeindevorschriften
oder Bauauflagen verletzen vielleicht
finden sich dann für die behördengründe
endlich einzuschreiten
so ein erklärtes Ziel weg mit den
reichsbürgerinnen aus Gutenberg mal
schauen vielleicht schaffen wir das ja
aber vielleicht schaffen auch nur dass
sie sich nicht weiter aussehen kann das
wäre doch schon ziemlich gut das
beschauliche dorfrotenberg ringt um
seine Zukunft das Ende der
Auseinandersetzung bleibt offen